[Music]
[Music]
I'm Glen urban Dean of the MIT Sloan
School of Management and it's my
privilege to welcome you to this fifth
lecture in our industry leaders in
technology management series this is
co-sponsored by the School of Management
and the School of Engineering we bring
to campus here the world's leading CEOs
to give us their guidance and wisdom you
may have been here last week when Jack
Smith was here from GM you'll probably
also remember our earlier speakers Alan
Alex Trotman from Ford and Gordon binder
from Amgen today it gives me a great
pleasure to introduce equally eminent
speaker dr. Andy Grove who's the
president and CEO of Intel Corporation
dr. groves life really shows graphically
the opportunities in America he came
here from Hungary in 1957 enrolled in
City College and got a bachelor's degree
in chemical engineering in 1960 went on
to get a PhD the University of
California in 1963 and in 1968 teamed up
with Gordon Moore and Bob Noyce then at
Fairchild Semiconductor and they formed
some little startup company called Intel
which has been the home for Andy for 30
years at this point a tremendous career
a tremendous company he's been one of
the driving forces behind making this
successful you may recall that five
years ago or so various people were
predicting that the US icy industry
would be out of business well in the
last year's 1992-95 under Andy's
leadership the sales at Intel have gone
from 4 billion to 16 billion the profits
from 650 million to 3.5 billion and the
stock price on average from 10 to over
65 so it's hard to find a more
successful track record for company
leadership dr. groves going to speak to
us today on exploiting the crisis points
challenging every
any and career and you don't have to
take too many notes because he's just
written a new book that describes many
of these ideas only the paranoid survive
and if you happen to see the latest
Forbes magazine Forbes says that this is
probably the best book written on
business by a business person since
Alfred Sloane's my years at General
Motors so welcome home and you're in
you're in good company here please
welcome me and joining with dr. grill
for this sign
[Applause]
first of all it is the mic working good
what I would like to do is first of all
stay nearby here that's okay with your
protocol and use this overhead projector
to walk through walk you through some of
the observations there are in fact the
kernel of that book and have been based
on my experience and laboratory tested
beta tested if you wish on the
competitive business school whose name
shall remain remain unnamed but it's on
the west coast and near where I live how
many of you are Business School is to
business students here how many are
engineers and jinuk school students now
how many of you are business school
students who how many of you have an
undergraduate degree in engineering
that's pretty good okay alright the
reason I'm asking this because I want to
tell you what the real title of this
book was intended to be and I didn't
want to miss my mark I wanted to call
this book's strategic inflection points
and it's meant for general purpose
audiences and my publisher wouldn't hear
of it and made a long story short long
short of it it got a catchy title but
that is what the book is about strategic
inflection point is my way of
visualizing and describing fundamental
change in the well-being of a business
fundamental change in the well-being of
the of an industry it's a curve more or
less going like this which I don't know
can the overflow people see this
there is a video setup for it okay the
hardest
time we all have it business it's not a
a break point in a curve if the curve
represents the well-being or the flow of
a business it is and exactly at the
subtle point where the curvature changes
we're going from convex to concave or
the other way around I never could
figure that out and it's exactly at that
point that the nature of the business
around us is changing and it's changing
in a subtle way but changing in a
profound and lasting fashion and those
people in a business who do not make the
adjustment to the new curvature going to
decline that's kind of the graphical
representation of what I'm talking about
and another way to look at this is to
look at the conditions under which the
businesses undergo or businesses in
general undergo strategic inflection
points and I trust the business school
students among you have studied in one
form or another camouflage as it might
have been Porter's competitive strategy
concept probably called five forces
diagram or something to take the brand
name of it is that right
yes okay that's what they do with the
other named school anyway Porter
material contribution by basically right
graphically depicting competitive forces
and I read it a little bit because I
amended it with another contribution
that actually came from a couple of
professors one at Harvard one at Yale
the six forces to broaden it that affect
the business customers power competitive
forces in inter interesting competitive
forces supply our forces of substitution
and adding to that complimentary people
who are crucial in adding additional
value to the value of the product in
question easiest way to look at it
Microsoft is our complementary Microsoft
software makes
into micro processors more valuable
Intel is Microsoft's complete
complimentary Microsoft software with an
Intel microprocessors would clearly not
be as valuable as it is with this is
sort of the general analysis of
describing how a business operates and
this is not what are we going to talk
about what we are going to look at it
what are we going to examine here is
what happens when one of those forces
becomes very very much larger than the
others and I want to call it an order of
magnitude and in order to not this order
of magnitude is not exactly trade
publication term I called it a 10x for
us a 10 for 10 for 10 times increase
relative to the other forces what
happens when there is such one of the
forces that determine the well-being of
a business really grows out of bound and
it is so big that it can distort the
picture and what tends to happen at
times like that is that the very nature
of the industry changes not the business
not the competitive well-being of the
business alone but the whole business
model changes and I give you an example
that comes from right from our own
industry on this one and on the left of
the diagram you would have maybe do the
business model of the computing industry
as it used to be performed in the 60s
70s 80s
computers were sold as vertically
integrated devices proprietary platforms
proprietary operating systems
applications developed for that
proprietary operating system and the
whole stack of things sold by Salesforce
that was unique to that enterprise then
came the personal computer which was in
fact a genuine almost quantitatively
correct with describable 10x force in
that its cost effectiveness relative to
mainframes or mini computers was about
tenfold right from the inception on and
it was clearly a toy and it was clearly
unreliable and it couldn't do the
software that was pertinent to business
processes but
so cost-effective that is represented at
an x-force and in front of our eyes in
the course of the decade of the 80s the
entire structure of the industry changed
from the vertical powers of computer
products competing with each other to a
completely horizontal industry in which
microprocessors compete with other micro
processors operating systems compete
with other microprocessor other
operating systems application software
in a packaged form like a bunch of
commodity goods like a bunch of
detergents compete for that shelf space
with other application software and
direct sales goes out as a means of
distribution distribution becomes all
indirect but in terms of your experience
is very difficult to imagine how
ridiculous the whole concept of selling
computers through the telephone and
sumail would have sounded to somebody
who was steeped in the computer industry
of the left side of the diagram I mean
it was it wasn't even laughable it was
people wouldn't even engage that idea so
that's how much it changed so the
business model changed under this part
of this 10x force from a particular way
of doing computing the completely
different view in computing and the time
period that I'm interested in talking
about and I'm interested in considering
is what happens in between those 2 by 2
diagrams I call it the valley of death
that's one way to discourage going to
describe it another way to describe it
is picture some kind of a graphical
figure being morphed into another
graphical figure a face being moved into
another face and it's in between then
the bits are all distorted and all
jumbled up when you can't make heads and
tails out of the diagram there's no
shape to things that is when managing an
enterprise and for that matter managing
a career are the trickiest tasks and
that's what we are talking about let me
give you a couple more examples to bring
some reality to this and
the 10 X force can come in a variety of
ways I described in the kids of the
computer industry it came through
technology higher power technology
brought a great deal of cost
effectiveness in the case of the Porter
diagram it K caused substitution in a
very large scale it can come in various
other ways if you are retailer in a
smaller medium town someplace in America
the strategic inflection point arrives
in the form of a bunch of surveyors who
come and start serving the property at
the in one of the most highly traveled
into intersection in town and then a
sign goes up future home of Walmart now
you say it was the difference there
never was just one retail store in this
town there always a bunch of them anyone
over that register we survived always
had competition I've competition now so
one more what the hell is the difference
and missus the TEDx force Walmart is not
just one more Comfort competitor
it is the largest retailer in the world
tuned tuned genetically tuned to operate
at same margins it's very high volumes
using information technology satellite
technologies transportation technologies
all fine-tuned to do that to a precision
that small-town retailer cannot conduct
their business is business in the same
fashion just thinking that's another
competitor or else they're gonna go
downhill on that curve so that's the
example when a competitive force will be
a 10x force sometimes these forces come
in the form of regulatory changes an
example of that is what happened in 1984
when in the form of the modified final
judgment George brought about the
deregulation of many decade old
countrywide monopoly that was the AT&T
at that time and the repercussions of
the change have been immense
and it they impacted the well-being of
not one company but a lotta calm but is
there certain impacted the well-being of
AT&T old a new impacted the well-being
of MCI sprint and untold alternative
service providers impacted the
well-being the regional operating
companies impacted the robbing of
customers and most importantly impacted
the well-being of probably hundred and
fifty thousand employees of the old AT&T
who are no longer working for any
telephone company so this is not a
change this is a cataclysmic change it
was a strategic inflection point and
very few people realized at that time I
was around at the time I was calling on
AT&T because one of our customers they
were confused it was like that the bits
in the middle of the morphing process
they didn't know what was going to
happen but none of them could foresee
the extent it was going to change their
well-being and the chair of their
business processes we talked about a
computer industry the one other thing
that I want to say is which we are in
the middle of the internet you know you
pick up any trade magazine any newspaper
any anything I'm either the Internet is
being beaten to death in the press but
the larger picture is that there is a
phenomenon coming here that is likely to
affect not just one industry like all of
these examples have but half a dozen
industries industries that don't even
know that this what helps
packet-switching have to do with the
media industry what the hell does the
internet has to do with the
entertainment industry in Hollywood what
does it have to do with the service
industries and yet
enormous industries that had kind of
minded their own business
never in under a few years ago even have
you heard the phrase will be more will
be restructured will have to undergo
over the next several years and valley
of death type transformation now exactly
how will that shape art I don't know ten
years I could come back if your interest
at not tell you exactly how it happened
just like I can tell you about the
computer industry but right now it's a
bunch of bits in a confused fashion and
we are just entering the valley of death
it is very confusing in the middle of it
that's not unusual that is what it's
like because the new business model is
doesn't take shape very clear clearly
and a lot of people have different ideas
on how it's gonna be and which is why of
course all the newspapers are filled
with very superficial speculation on the
shape of the future so to sum this the
strategic inflection point happens when
there's a major change in the
competitive environment can be
technological regulation 10x competition
for force and a key element is that it
is very often and I don't know if always
because I have made an exhaustive study
of it but very often the first signs of
it the first recognition of it does not
come from senior management people like
me but come from people who are in the
frontlines of the key activities of the
corporation sales force is very likely
to realize changing customer preferences
much before sales management is now do
they understand that it's a change of
customer preferences no they just
understand something that used to work
doesn't work anymore then you go home
and tell that story and they can't make
a coherent story out of it so they get
thrown out go go wait just work harder
and the fact of the matter is something
changed in them and because it is so
murky they can't articulate the story I
mean the internet is a perfect example
people who understood those things
however people who were users of the
internet but they didn't understand how
big was going to be or they understood
that their little world was suddenly
intruded by a bunch of people who had no
business being on the Internet
and I see a number of nodding heads and
those people probably realize that
something is changing in the aggregate a
long time before most people in
corporate management even had a whiff of
it what is going to happen when that
happens is that individuals like that I
got to start turning into being
casandra's and because mostly this
change is not for the better the most is
change is something that worked doesn't
work and our products are no longer
there sneering at them in our case when
we you know Intel was the same kind of
the memory company we pioneer
semiconductor memories because the
leaders in semiconductor memories in the
mid 80s the Japanese came and became a
10x force for us in seven after memories
and what are the first signs as I look
back I didn't look at it at that time as
a sign I look at it is a winding sales
force but one of the first signs that I
looked back that should have tipped us
off was our sales force in Japan saying
that the customers are not as respectful
of them as they used to be and there was
such a telling story in retrospect if I
look back on the curve that's when the
curve was beginning to enter in the
inflection point they weren't because
they knew that their internal capability
the customers internal capability the
semiconductor sister Division was going
to run circles around us they knew that
and that attitude changed to our sales
force or sales or told us us being
management ignored it we ignored it when
they showed up here we ignored it
as we were starting to lose market share
and the people in our company who
realized what was going on was our group
of production planners who started
adjusting our factory loading away from
memories toward microprocessors why but
we had better business opportunities in
micro processors we made more money in
micro processors so we're not making a
big fanfare 100 wafer lost by 100 wafer
laws they just moved the production Lots
from memories to micro processors so by
the time those of us who ran the company
started facing up to that that our core
business between memories was going away
because of these incremental actions of
the our finance people and production
planners and lower level management we
were much less exposed to the memory
business we have gradually rationalized
our factoring processors so we still
have to cut back we still have to shut
down factories but much less then had
these casandra's not taking matters in
their own hands so spontaneous actions
through frontline or low-level employees
who are much closer to the action is a
very key element in causing adjustment
in the business structure of a company
that's a key element what tends to
happen is when I'm sorriest to this off
too early what tends to happen is
there's at times like this there's a
growing divergence dissonance between
the actions of people who are close to
the actions and the comprehension and
statements of senior management's like
myself I call that strategic dissonance
because a corporation in its daily
action is beginning to do something
deviant from the stated mission values
competencies that continues to get
articulated in the management so one of
the big tell-tale signs in a business
that it is struggling with a strategic
inflection point is this growing and
seemingly irreconcilable difference
between what the company does and what
the company says it's supposed to be
doing
that's it's not because people involved
are dumb or phony or hypocritical or
anything like that but because senior
management who is responsible for the
articulation who is giving the
interviews that the employees read in
the newspaper doesn't know it yet the
employees know is not real the senior
management doesn't know it yet is real
that's a terribly strong sign and I'm
not gonna name names because it gets a
little closer to present time but
there's very relevant examples and but
and of that taking place in the recent
past in the past in the information
technology industries to cope with it
the cope with this process requires
fundamental changes in your business
outlook fundamental changes in the
definition of what your business is and
what it might be fundamental changes in
the core competencies the capabilities
of the corporation if you've been doing
this all along like in interest games
we've been in the micro but we had been
in the microprocessor business for 10
years before this change occurred we had
a lot of capabilities we are the option
of abandoning our traditional business
and emphasizing an emerging business if
we didn't we would have been up the
creek without a paddle it is very
important for that reason alone to
cultivate additional and corollary
supporting competencies so that we're
shifts take place you got places to
shift to more about it in a few minutes
a key issue that we need to deal with is
organizations corporations individuals
dealing with the carriers governments
are constantly surrounded by indications
of monumental changes and one of the
they are not all real things for every
real inflection point causing change
that you have to deal with there are 10
items that are really not much more than
noise when you look back retrospectively
so how do you tell one from the other
and I wish I was able to give you a
little diskette that you run this
program fill in the blanks and it will
tell you if I can't I have looked at
that thought through a variety of
examples of this and some examples of
may mean something to some of you 10 12
years ago there was a big raging trend
toward x-ray lithography in our industry
and particularly Japanese competitors
were investing very heavily to it and
some Americans felt that unless we make
that change in the language that I'm
using today we got to go down the hill
and decline in a strategic inflection
point we analyzed the seven ways through
sunday decided it was really a spurious
noise again using today's language and
you turn out to be right x-ray
lithography the last ten years hasn't
gone anywhere visible light and
ultraviolet light to the tog rafi
doesn't matter what those things
conventional techniques X could be
extended much more and we were right and
an interesting question does that mean
that x-ray lithography will never go
anywhere it doesn't x-ray lithography as
a threat may have been a bit of noise
1012 years ago and may become a
strategic inflection point a year from
now five years from now or ten years
from now so there is not a general deal
that a certain phenomenon is right or
wrong is is or is not a strategic
inflection point it is in the context of
the time
contact the state of the business the
context of the evolution of the
technology another example that I want
to touch on is risk technology as in
microprocessors that was a late eighties
phenomenon and it was taken very
seriously by a lot of players as an 10x
force a 10x better way of building micro
processors that could in fact approve
the structure of the business and create
a lot of trouble for established players
like Intel and in fact a lot of people
at Intel thought that might be the case
so we had enormous raging debate and a
major development to hedge our bets of a
RISC processor whose advocates and whose
designers believed it was a 10x force
and we continue to pursue pursue our
regular standard architecture whose
designers and developers thought it
wasn't so this debate took place very
heavily internally and it was a very
expensive proposition both in terms of
double investment streams and in terms
of the wear and tear on our people and
our management including myself because
I didn't understand the issues involved
here at all this was way outside of my
technical competence and I had to rely
on the advice of people who all of a
sudden didn't Barry said good morning to
each other they were so emotional on the
subject now we pursued apparel
development that up to a point and then
eventually out of old as debate and
debate is the impact one of the most
important ways of dealing with this
thing we came to the conclusion it was
not a strategic inflection point that
more almost literally it was not a 10x
improvement it was a 2 to 3x improvement
and is likely to be less and less as
time goes on
turns out again in that time frame we
were right
but before we were right half the people
who revolved the RISC processer left the
company the relationships for that were
torn up for the largest part never
healed so these things are not fun and
easy processes even inside a company
even among people
know each other well I'm gonna switch to
a different subject so we have
opportunity two questions which is this
is what I dealt with is methods of
recognition is a phenomenon strategic
infection port or not but let's suppose
we are past that stage we are entering a
strategic inflection point Dean urban
where are you is it proper to take
therefore lecture to remove his jacket
thank you no I'm not gonna get that
naked in a school so you are in one of
them you are in there value of the death
valley of death and subject I want to
talk for a few minutes as what are some
of the techniques that you can do to get
through it and the best way to look at
that is this process has two stages the
first half and the second half the first
half is again people keep in mind is
morphing metaphor you are entering from
an orderly to a disorder the state of
affairs from a phase that you recognize
to a bunch of mixed-up bits and things
are terribly confusing the people the
casandra's that come and bring you the
stories from the field from the very
first don't make any sense you don't be
comfortable anymore so what you need to
do is let lose of the brain sort of let
chaos reign in the organization about
let experimentation take place now the
natural state of organizations is chaos
that applies to all organizations its
corollary the second law of
thermodynamics
so you ordinary ordinarily management is
there to fight the dispersion of the
forces in the company and bring some
cohesion in there so this is not a
natural act for management letting chaos
reign particularly not a natural act
when many thing is getting a little
uncomfortable about the state of the
business and I'm sitting there watching
these things I'm not that comfortable
what is my reaction going to be I want
to pull in the reigns not like go and in
reality in this stage we have to
constantly have to discipline ourselves
to letting things go because the only
way we are going to put some shape and
certainty into this ambiguity in our
business model is to let a bunch of
things go on and then watch them like a
hawk not I'm not gonna do the
experiments but I can very easily watch
all those experiments and see which one
gets traction and which one and I mean I
don't actually mean technical
experiments although sometimes that
might be there a question what funding
development program that I mutually
contradictory and you gotta get a lot of
stuff back talk on this right now you
know how can you give money for this and
not give money for that
and you are all confused you have your
head up in the wrong place at cetera
etcetera etcetera but you have to bear
with that because at this point you
simply are not in a position to know so
this is the phase but I say let chaos
reign do a lot of experimentation and
one I'm not covering every item and this
fall so don't get them tried not to stay
synchronous with the fall there but what
is extremely important ideally is to
start doing this experimentation at a
time when your existing business is
strong it provides a protective bubble
over the totality of your business now
this is so damn logical it's not funny
it's time to start playing with new
things that start at time to start
experimenting this time to start
investing in those new things to develop
those competencies is when your core
business is wrong and not what is real
life real life is I want to do that and
when I go to my best guy here and said
okay you're gonna go on this emerging
stuff and every general manager is gonna
jump on me
how can you pull him out of the business
that pays all of our salaries says okay
no no no I was kidding I was kidding is
a bad idea bad idea let him let me take
him and he came up way below him or the
the other guy in the ranking let him do
the new business and he's really not
very good even only keeping him for
traditions sake nothing personal then we
put him on the new area and guess what
the new area is not going to succeed now
is it not going to succeed because it
was a bad idea in the first place or is
it not going to succeed because we put
our second class people on developing it
that's how it goes in real life and you
know on the other hand I keep coming
back to that management is not you don't
get drafted to be a manager you you know
you enlist to be a manager you like all
the various elements of it one flip side
of it is you have to do things that
require self-discipline it's kind of
like dieting and exercise and a bunch of
stuff that you don't necessarily want to
do but you do because you're good for
you making choices like that you've got
to do because it comes with the
territory
having said that very few people use the
business bubble to make their choices
they hang on to the business bubble they
want to extend it and the under-invest
in the experimentation with the result
that when things happen they're wrong
people are in the wrong territory and
I'm not talking about them I'm talking
about me literally in that situation
where when we were in the DRM business
in the production planners very cleverly
over some period of time got us out of
gear and production and rammed up
microprocessor production that was good
because the production planners could do
it but only senior management could
assign development resources
development laboratories to do certain
lines of work so our best laboratory was
working on what microprocessors know and
they were doing a phenomenal job they
were developing the world's first CMOS
DRAM faster than anybody else's
including the Japanese manufacturers and
it was completely useless because we
buckled it didn't have any factories in
the walk in the works to produce them we
didn't have any real intention to put
them into production in the meanwhile
the product that we were starving from
development resources for exactly the
valar exercise that I have laid out was
the second generation version of the 386
which happened to be the stuff that led
to those spectacular results that Dean
urban described in the introduction so
you know you don't have to go very far
to see examples of it we corrected it
but we corrected it kind of my universal
constant for my my own carrier every
decision that I've ever ended up making
that turn out to be a right decision I
made a minimum a year late this one who
probably made some reason
more like year-and-a-half to do a
two-year late we took that team and put
them on the second generation 386 and
way they did it and fortunately we were
still ahead of the competition so that
we did okay with it
but in a more demanding business
environment it would have been too
little too late then comes the second
phase the morphing process continues the
bits are beginning to gel and you begin
to see the outlines of the new picture
and at this point now you can do what
you've been wanting to do pull in the
reins at this point is time to take
stock of those experimentation and make
order and decide what we are going to do
is this and that that and interestingly
by now your people may have gotten used
to chaos and they kind of like here like
I tell you organizations like chaos so
this is not exactly a highly popular act
either at the time it comes the only
difference is that if you
like most companies that you're not
doing this in the middle of a benign
business bubble but you're doing it when
you're in trouble people will support
harsh actions because they want
leadership to drag them out of the mess
that they are in the catch is you know
the reason I have two hands so I can do
on the one hand on the other hand
constantly on the other hand of this one
is that you you the leader of that
organization or you the leader of your
own career I'm not that sure just
beginning to see that picture gel as
you're moving across the strategic if
the DeMorgan process but you're not very
sure but you have to act as if you were
so you have to pull in the reins a
commit yourself to a course as a course
of action at a time when your knowledge
and your certainty lags way behind where
you are where you are it's a very
difficult process a very imperfect
process it's a process that is fraught
with dangers because by committing
yourself to that you're committing
yourself wrong you're sunk but if you
don't commit yourself your song for sure
because in most of the situation's
you're living in a competitive
environment where there's very little
tolerance for error but if you're not
committing yourself you're not going to
commit an error you simply are giving
time to your competition
and there's kind of a universal law in
business the only thing there is in
business is time you give time to
somebody else you take it away from
yourself that's all you got so
hesitation transfers time to your
competition and that time it never will
come back so the earliest moment make a
work up your courage to commit yourself
to
the training on the kiyose is the time
to act I've talked about a bunch of
things here and some of those things
have a very psychobabble tone to it and
that height is managers are people their
employees are people and work and
they're living in the careers and their
long-term success is very important to
each of these individuals involved so
when things go bad you're going through
the same stages as you go through and
personal catastrophes you have to go
through the usual stages of denial which
is very very strong that is why you want
to shoot the casandra's because your
denial of this new thing that you don't
want to deal with that you don't know
how to deal with is so strong you work
your way through escapism I have this
deep-seated suspicion that the
predominant reason people engage in big
time acquisitions is to escape from
dealing with a strategic inflection
point in their own business in their own
core business
there's nothing is as seductive as
staying of flying from one place to the
other staying up all night so with your
lawyers and your investment bankers and
calling a press conference and being on
the front page of the newspaper the next
day how does that compare with figuring
out which factories to shut down and
which one would you rather do and it is
so tempting to immerse yourself into
stuff like that as a legitimate escape
none escape like I go into golf course
or go on a safari to Africa but a
legitimate escape I'm working real hard
to do that
I don't know if this is true I don't
know how to study but I do have that
suspicion but when you get out of this
and the escape didn't work you move on
to the acceptance and pert into action
and the question here is do you do it in
time enough or do you wait until you
fritter the weight your resources and
the very large extent this is a an issue
of human makeup as much as anything else
last point I want to make everything I
have set here applies to your careers
and you know I'm not talking to you with
a bunch of CEOs of corporations now I'm
talking to you as a bunch of CEOs of
your own little business you know starts
at the top of your head and ends at your
toes that's your corporations you've
been investing in it heaven knows I
don't know purpose $30,000 a year or
whatever these are the charges here and
before and you're gonna continue to and
it's yours to manage and we are in a
very different era than my generation
managed careers in my generation could
assume that when we went to work for an
enterprise that enterprise could provide
us with a measure of stability that
would guide us through in a very smooth
fashion the inflection point that always
came that's not new always around
enterprises are not going through
inflection points of their own that
doesn't guarantee their own survival
so enterprises are far more preoccupied
with their own survival today than they
were a generation ago and therefore they
are less able physically less able and
emotionally and interest why the
concentration was less able to deal with
the survival of the many little couriers
many little businesses delirium
is represent this some of the favorite
cliches of business life today make this
problem worse you know we love
globalization globalization means that
the world is our oyster we can sell a
product everywhere from here to Gen dune
globalization also means that every
person every working person of the same
general training same general business
occupation in the world competes with
you
the devore four companies are complete
for your company in a brief period of 30
years from the 60s to the 90s the United
States in the aggregate has gone from an
almost dominant industrial power to one
of the leading industrial powers if you
look at that as a market analysis being
a dominant industrial power you know
diamond power your industry versus being
one of the contenders back into the
Porter model dealing with substitution
dealing with new entrants Dean dealing
with intense intra-industry rivalry life
has gotten a lot tougher for the United
States economy consequently life has
gotten a lot tougher for companies that
make up the United States economy
consequently those companies are much
less able to it's not that they became
venal mad ability in evil they're simply
less able to provide the style of career
development and carrier maintenance that
they used to do it if they don't do it
who's gonna do it and I'm advocating
basically doing the same concept of
strategic analysis I apply to your
career and foremost among those
watch for strategic inflection points
work on separating
signal from the noise and we complete
conclude that its signal experiment
first and the pouring rains and commit
yourself and discipline yourself to
overcome the denial the various other
human foibles that will come in the way
in your own Terrier as well as in your
business so that's all I have and I will
take questions from both here and
outside
[Applause]
who also produces a very high-quality
yeah from taking market share
how does in Turkey our competitors like
Texas Instruments who also produce high
quality chips from taking market share
you know back in the mid eighties when
we almost died and went through a
strategic inflection point and we came
out of it I came out of it with a very
strong and very controversial D to then
not so controversy today like I said all
of these stories are a lot easier
luckily or 10 years later then
very controversial decision that we will
focus on micro processors first second
and third we will put him was a pointing
at you a micro processor and everybody
else that we got with the best
development of micro processors and
we're going to invest in the best
microprocessor factories in the best
microprocessor design tools and this
work for us and over time our expertise
has led to reinforcing positive feedback
if you wish the better became the more
we were able to attract the best people
the more we are able to get the
attention of people other companies who
design development tools that are tuned
more for our needs than for somebody
else's so it has become easier and we
have not merged with anyone we have not
bought a Hollywood studio
not done any listings we are very very
maniacally focused company on
microprocessors that's all no more to it
you know we worked pretty hard because
Ghana like the phrase suggests we're
pretty paranoid company we are worried
about not any one or one of them in
particular but in the aggregate that we
like our business it's a good business
and we intend to sell a product to every
socket and we pursue it like the your
startup fighting for a life but that's
an attitudinal cultural issue but in
terms of business strategy the single
word is we focus like a laser beam now
just when you have questions if you
could wait for the microphone then they
there are approximately 150 to 200
people outside this room yeah I was
going so uh two questions yeah why don't
you but just have him get the microphone
so they can hear the question outside
and they will have some questions from
outside I just wanted to ask you about
China and I was wondering if you see
that as a strategic inflection point
with a number of different things still
waiting to evolve with the bits coming
around and trying to be a little bit
more definite what do you see is the
major challenges in trying to decipher
when the noise of China will become a
true signal and grow as much as
everyone's expecting it to now do they
hear the question outside okay with the
mic they do okay
this is a very complicated issue and I'm
gonna try to maybe oversimplify it a
little bit but the brief answer to your
question is yes I do
I see China representing major change in
the global business environment major
change for the for for industries and
commerce in general major change for the
information technology industry is a
major change for Intel and where you
really think about it it goes a little
bit more to go a little bit more detail
in that it is not merely that is 1.2
billion people
it is their population their market size
their competence skill and educational
level their ability to focus back you
know it's awesome the influence that
China is a country has on Chinese
nationals all over the world the
combination of that is an economic force
that I think in ten years time we're
going to look back and look at what the
exercise that we have had a piece of
each Japan in the eighties as a fire
drill outside question why don't you
shake one more here we're okay if you as
a Mike my question is about the new
paradigm in the client-server business
in a client-server paradigm you don't
really need a very powerful
microprocessor and also there is a trend
to move towards the lien client which
doesn't necessarily need a lot of
powerful microprocessor such as the one
offered by Intel my question is how
would you prepare Intel to compete in
this kind of new paradigm sort of
transition is as you say it from one
business core to another now the problem
I have with questions that state an
assumption as an embedded as part of the
question is that I don't know how to
answer it except as a hypothetical
situation I do not believe that
client-server computer computing does
not require powerful clients I believe
the opposite I believe furthermore and
the data are plentiful on this that
trends in terms of general computational
past present and future put more burden
on the clients rather than less burden
on the class
and just so I don't get trapped and
describing what I mean if we kept plot
up in a semi-log plot turning on an
emulation and network connected pcs of
today and network connected pieces with
with a modern client-server application
for instance the stuff that we are using
with distributed data data entry
processes today where most of the
execution takes place on the client but
we can extrapolate that and put in
distributed objects and the trend on a
semi-log plot your client power just
continues on so you know it is the
subject we are fairly involved with but
the upshot of it is that I don't see a
trend away from that semi-log plot which
is more client more part of the client
at all in the horizon however let's take
this suppose that was the case I would
tend on a soapbox and I would get my
buddy here and move them into developing
some clients because if trends go to our
sync clients I can delay those trends
but I can't change them and the
implication will probably be that
Intel's business would be a lot less
rich lower margin and etc there are all
those things but I would want to lead in
that lower margin business the same way
as I lead in the higher margin ok we'll
take one from the outside if Intel is
focused on microchips now what is your
bubble of security for the next
inflection point and how do you balance
focus and a bubble of other directions
specifically well you can't again
question ok
we had a two ways I could do this I
can't argue with a written question here
whether can't question their even
question but so let me tell you my
invitation what is Intel's next
strategic focus were going to be given
and what's your next inflection point is
I see it we set ourselves we kind of
drove a stake in the ground in the early
part of this decade that the next
evolution and development of computing
is going to be I'm looking at the in
urban as if here as there as the
question is going to be communication
based applications of computing and we
started doing exactly the kind of things
that we are talking about amassing
competences in that and it wasn't very
clear what the communicating
applications were going to be able
application vision migrated around or
first ideas were email embedded with
rich multimedia data types and then we
went from that to video conferencing and
then the internet arrived and what's
common in all of these they involve data
communications and and the import and
they involve rich data types images
sound video data elements back to your
point all of them requiring a lot of
hyper microprocessors on both ends
actually of the wire but what we have
done in this is we have plugged away for
probably five six years on bringing in
expertise because it's not a natural
skill at microprocessor company if you
had to hire people from places like
Belcore and various other communications
out the data communications companies
from colleges and we built up quite an
expertise in this and we continue to
push on that and we look for
developments of businesses that fit two
criteria use personal computing and and
enhance the use of personal computing in
communications applications
and do so in such a way that we can make
a business out of providing that kind of
application yesterday we had a major
symposium in New York City that was
called wired for management initiative
or an Intel supposing we filled the
Madison Square Garden conference center
not the boxing arena but over 3,000
people came for a day-long of sort of
technical presentation demonstrations
whose element was basically gelling all
all of these expertise to deliver
servicing of client computer clients
from a in a client-server pcbs
client-server environment through a
remote underwire down the wire
management capability we have become
this is not a gigantic business yet but
I think it is a decent business a
growing business and a very important
business for letting the world progress
toward this notion of communicating
applications we are the world's leader
in management software group level
management software applications not
well known I mean better known today
than it was yesterday but it is a result
of that so we are experimenting we are
building on core competencies and we
have in fact moved people along my
little skit into that field who have
been very proficient leaders in
microprocessor so what it all work will
it be significant was a bet right we
know that in ten years time
I was wondering can you hear me yeah I
was wondering if you think that there
might be such thing as too much control
over an industry what I'm trying to
understand is that you all have a very
big influence over the industry that
you're working in and as such I mean
you're controlling a lot of that of the
value chain and I'm wondering is in the
long term if you feel responsible for
more than your particular company which
is huge and a lot of employees but I'm
wondering how you if you if you feel
responsible for the company beyond for
the industry beyond your company and if
so what kind of actions do you take to
to to do that a very interesting
question let me start with you kind of
segue through several questions here but
let me try with one of them all right
what do we feel responsible for which is
a good question we have a you know very
healthy share of the microprocessor
market did one thing that's clear for us
yeah we cannot grow a whole lot more by
increasing that market share some place
in the last several years our corporate
priority has changed in a very
significant way to growing the personal
computing industry not growing our share
of the personal computing industry but
undertaking initiatives which may or may
not turn into businesses the one I just
described being an example if it turns
into business not a gigantic business
but maybe it's not one turn into a
business but it will grow the whole
industry in that sense we are working on
behalf of the entire industry because
our entire focus these girls grows grows
in the process of doing that we have
adopted a certain set of internal rules
and regulations which in a simplest form
is being extremely open about what we do
and not
closing up specifications except when it
comes to the very crown jewels of our
company which is microprocessor design
other than that all of our initiatives
are industry-wide initiatives now having
said that let me tell you who I feel the
biggest obligation to and that's
consistent with this drive I feel our
biggest obligation is not to the members
of the industry but to the members of
the larger community of information
technology users who really determine
where the pieces are in or pieces are
out thin clients are in the thing
clients are out where their pieces
become boring or not boring we all have
a very very strong user focus and we
study user communities in terms of
consumers small businesses large
businesses internationally constantly we
have we have various formal dialogues
with representative bodies of them.we
merchandise to them and every once in a
while when we run into trouble we'll
find there's a pentium story we end up
having to service them directly even
though we didn't actually sell anything
to them so the answer to your question
yes we feel responsible for the industry
not because we have such good guys but
because the only way we can grow is if
the industry grows and the way we intend
to discharge responsibilities is
constant focus on the evolving needs or
potential needs of the user community
hello i today about complementary or
complementary as one of the six forces
in that five forces diagram and I think
we all understand how Microsoft fits in
with Intel and how that complements
Intel's business my question is I'm
curious how your joint development
agreements with hewlett-packard how
that's going to fit in and looking into
the future how Intel and hewlett-packard
are going to be able to complement each
other I don't think that fits the
category of complement or it's not all
business relationships are complementary
in this sense of two capabilities
complimenting each other in the context
of the industry structure what we're
doing if you look packard is business
arrangement where we got some technology
from them and they are going to receive
in various forms that i'm not at liberty
to discuss payback for that technology
and out of that will come another
generation of microprocessor the general
extension for microprocessors run to
64-bit with that is going to be an
industry standard product so this is
more a kind of a mixing of two
organization generic pools technically
speaking and it's a quid pro quo and
arrangement between two companies when
the dust settles hewlett-packard will be
a computer manufacturer and will use
Intel microchips just like it does today
probably in a more extensive fashion as
we transition to 64 bits and those micro
processors will be better for them and
for the rest of the industry and for the
users back in the previous questions
because they put the technology in there
now
HP thought about the technology long
before they put that in the on the table
and they realized that the technology is
value is only as good as the spread of
the technology through the industry that
they could not really
specialize and make eternity into
commercial value given that in the
personal computing area or in the
computing area all together they have a
relatively small share of the total
market so they made the conscious
decision to adopt to this horizontal
open industry model with their
technology through us and will become a
distributor of the particular part of
the technology that we incorporate into
their products for the rest of the
industry and then a negotiated something
in return for that so I don't think it's
going to change the nature of the
industry I think it is going to however
result in a better 64-bit microprocessor
generation that we ourselves just with
our own genetic pool could have been
able to generate okay last question is
from an undergraduate given what you
know now what advice would you give
yourself
in 1968 about running and building Intel
I on a personal basis I could comment on
a corporate basis I really can't because
I don't you know you gotta put this into
perspective I was 32 years old when I
went to Intel I was a research engineer
I never went near production had never
gone your production land the like my
biggest worry when I went to inter was I
didn't know how I'm gonna earn my keep
and I'm meanings all seriousness so I
adapted to the situation I did okay but
I think if the early stages I was
somewhat hampered by this question you
know what is a research guy like me
gonna do in a commercial startup so I
don't know if that's a general adviser
jump problem or general advice but to
myself I would say don't worry about it
it's gonna work out okay yeah
as to how Inca could have done better in
those early days I we started out
extremely well we hit recessions and
with you know very bumps and grind but I
strategically focus on one thing which
was semiconductor memories we started
much in the same kind of hedged or
technological bets in granted for a
while three different directions we
jettisoned one pretty early jettison the
second one after we saw that MOS
memories worked
jettisons bipolar memories a few years
later so the first few years
strategically I can't see even
retrospect what we could have done
better later we've started getting
trapped which is a big lesson getting
trapped with our own success and on our
own legacy and were slower to changed
with opportunities and the responding to
the threats then we might have but
that's that's what this whole thing was
about so thank you very much for coming
and thanks for your questions just as a
final announcement that dr. groves book
is actually on sale outside and since my
background is marketing you promised me
a commission for every book you sell
it's the greatest book you will ever get
and our next lecture will be on December
3rd mr. de Simoni who is the CEO of 3m
corporation so continuing a great
tradition here